Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
for my continuing exploration of the Marvel-Verse
I thought it would be fun to talk about the
Doctor Strange Movie that will be happening
during phase 3.
It hasn’t been officially announced, but
behind every rumor there is a little truth
and Marvel is meeting almost every major actor
in Hollywood for the role.
At least every major actor that can convincingly
pull off a trippy magic based movie.
So in this video I’ll list my top 5 stories
I think would make a good first movie for
the character and then I’ll talk about some
of the actor rumors.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m trying to do one big Marvel Movie video
every Tuesday in addition to my Agents of
SHIELD videos.
Be sure to subscribe and join in on the fun.
So top 5 Doctor Strange stories.
Number 5 - Essential Doctor Strange volume
1.
This is the collected works of Stan Lee and
Steve Ditko’s original run on the character.
The original origin story.
Expect to see a Stan Lee Cameo in the movie
and at least some easter eggs if not straight
up lines from characters.
Because this was written in the early 60s
it became a benchmark for weird.
And right now I think the Guardians of The
Galaxy is doing that for superhero movies.
Almost every subsequent re-telling of the
origin story borrows aspects of Stan Lee’s
original.
So the movie will at least pay homage to these
stories.
One notable change I expect to see would be
using shortening the long prose speeches.
Stan Lee likes to talk a lot, and Stan Lee’s
Doctor Strange consequently talked a lot.
So yes, expect any movie version of the character
to speechify more than the Hulk and a slightly
less than chatty Tony Stark.
Number 4 - Triumph and Torment.
This would have to be changed a little bit,
but it involves Doctor Strange getting Doctor
Doom’s help to rescue Doom’s mother from
Mephisto.
It’s done by Hellboy’s Mike Mignola and
reads like super high drama romance Downton
Abbey style crossed with a dream you could
only have if you were really high.
What premise could be cooler than Doctor Strange
and Doctor Doom go to hell.
Mephisto like Dormammu is a really big villain.
So I’ll be curious if they keep those types
of characters in the movie.
They cut Mandarin out of the original Iron
Man movie.
Due to copyright they’d have to swap Doctor
Doom for another character.
Number 3 - A Separate Reality.
Most people refer to this as Frank Brunner’s
Run.
He was the artist.
Not the writer.
I would put it up with Bryan K Vaugahn’
run, which would come later.
The story is an excellent blend of a lot of
the science fiction aspects of the marvel
universe and the fantasy elements of magic.
Strange ends up fighting this other Sorceror
trying to become god and it really reminds
me of the original Infinity Gauntlet storyline
where a villain tries to achieve ultimate
power so that he can fill a hole inside himself,
replace something that’s missing.
Like hugs.
And ultimately it turns into a story about
redemption.
For all you anime fans out there it also really
reminded me of fullmetal alchemist brotherhood.
It’s stories like this that make me really
excited to see how an enlightened being like
Strange is going to deal with the man of pure
science like Tony Stark.
But that’s really the job of whoever ends
up writing the script.
Making Fantasy blend well with Science Fiction.
Kind of like the original Star Wars Trilogy.Which
Disney also happens to own.
Number 2 - The Flight of Bones.
This was part of the great noir Marvel Knights
miniseries era and invoked this really cool
detective story setting Doctor Strange after
Dormammu.
Think of it as being like Doctor Strange written
like Sherlock Holmes.
Number 1 - The Oath by Bryan K Vaughan (or
New Avengers) - has to lead into AV3/Infinity.
This was an amazing re-telling of the origin
story that solved the really problematic aspects
of magic by not making them the focus of the
story.
It also does a great job of balancing the
more philosophical aspects of wielding limitless
power with the fun magical battles in other
dimensions.
The big issue with a Doctor Strange story
that’s different from say Captain America
is that he can’t punch his problems away.
And he has to balance really dark power and
white magic.
Since this would all help lead into the more
magical aspects of the infinity gems, Thanos
and the infinity gauntlet in phase 3.
You should also check out Doctor Strange’s
recent appearances in New Avengers.
It’s essentially an illuminati story, so
I could totally see them using it as inspiration
for how all these new different heroes come
together in outer space.
Now it’s your turn though, let me know which
Doctor Strange origin story you think they’ll
use and how they’ll change it to make it
more modern.
Just to address the Johnny Depp rumors, he
had a meeting a long long time ago before
Marvel ever created their unified movie universe
and phases.
So if they do get a big actor, it will be
someone else.
We can always talk about that in another video.
I’ve been doing a lot of phase 3 videos,
and there are still a few other films we could
talk about like the Black Widow movie they’re
working on or Black Panther.
Or more Guardians of The Galaxy.
Let me know whether you want to talk about
another movie next week or if you want to
talk about actors or something else all together.
Right now click here to learn all about my
top 5 picks for the Captain America 3 story
and click here for my character breakdown
of Guardians of The Galaxy.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!